a stoolie food a couple of times already
and dandy great price to brown are the
booze of the fans truly great I'm not
sure it might even motivate them a
little bit more like this one LeBron
James up top of the booze of the fans
truly great I'm not sure it might even
motivate them a little bit more like
this one LeBron James up
[Music]
Davis with the fade away and they call
his number Anthony Davis now to apply
from the fear not a big deal at all and
bounce back with a huge game tonight the
guy's a great player had a bad night
Anthony Davis with six points now after
he rolls that hook in some light snow
Gregg Popovich just died a little bit
cuz I skipped about tense thank you
thank you I love the kids where Daniels
gives it up to alex caruso
Rondo also has one remember the pelicans
of hi Davis punching it all
[Applause]
Williams hits it out to heart made his
previous three couple years ago he led
the Lakers in three-point shooting
percentages
Davis made a rim run great pass by Bruce
Lee I'll give him credit I don't do it
at the moment I'm not sure how you could
argue
and he Davis spins inside and got it to
go and dreams that's up against England
Davis with the mismatch on holiday Davis
and Holliday are friends but this isn't
show friends this is show business and
you see it with the ratings
we have devalued the regular season so
long that now as Davis it's a three that
now and these are outstanding player
that doesn't get enough credit
throughout this league
Anthony Davis with the easy money post
up on the shorter Williams of rebounding
and holding his own in the paint Davis
inside and made it look easy like the
drill
Jackson Hayes meanwhile